Hello. And welcome back to the complete guide
to Spin. Today, we're taking a look at
a new feature of Spin, which is key
value
storage. This is an awesome new feature that
opens up the ability to save and retrieve
state with a very simple API
and our WebAssembly context.
One of the classic examples out there online
for WebAssembly is writing your own URL shortener.
Why? Well, because WebAssembly has very fast startup
times, typically in microseconds.
So for URL shortener, this makes a lot
of sense. As requests come in, we can
actually send that redirect response faster than traditional
serverless workflows.
But what if we want to offer dynamic
charted URLs? And by dynamic I mean not
hard coded and the code itself like most
of the examples online show including
the one in the Fermian documentation.
Well we can use the spin key value
store using HTTP
verbs
such as put to store your short URLs.
Use the get verb, find and redirect where
possible and even support delete for when we
want to remove URLs that no longer should
be shortened.
This allows us to provide an HTTP API
to add, remove and fetch our URLs
which is pretty neat. Well, let's take a
look using Fermion
one point o, which launched just last week.
Let's have some fun. Okay.
What do we have?
Well, we're in another directory called spin dash
k v. In this directory, we have a
brand new spin project. Well, almost brand new.
I've written some code, which uses a rust
SDK. We can tell that because we have
a cargo dot toml. We also have a
spin.toml,
which we've seen a few of before. However,
this one has one unique change. If we
scroll down to here, you'll see that under
the component configuration block,
we have key value stores. And we have
a list of the value default.
At the time of recording this video and
for spin one point o, the only value
we can use in this list is the
default key value store. However, in the future,
more options
may become available.
Stay tuned. So we have this default value
for now and we have our spend project.
Now you may be wondering, where do all
the key values live when we run spend
locally on our machine? And that is a
great question. Thank you for asking. Inside the
dot spin directory, you will find a dot
DB file.
This is a SQLite
database,
which is used by Spin to store all
of your configuration
or at least whatever you decide to store
in the key value store. So let's pop
open lib dot r s. And here, you'll
see that we pull in the key value
create,
which has a store and an error type.
These are not that important right now and
we will come back to them shortly. If
we scroll down the line 13, you'll see
that we ask the store
to give us the default key value store.
This does have the potential to fail and
if you want to capture the error and
match on it yourself,
well, feel free.
For today's example, we're just going to use
the question mark and let it work it
out itself.
And because our handler expects
a result, it's okay for it just to
throw and propagate the error to the runtime.
Next, we grab the short URL
from the request URI,
where the short URI is just the path
that being slash hello slash a b c
slash hello a b c, whatever.
Next, we do a match on the method.
Now we're going to rely on HTTP verbs
for this very simple API.
That being when we get a GET request
on a path, we're going to look up
that
path and the key value store
for a redirect URL.
If it doesn't exist, we'll return a http
not found slash four zero four. And if
it is, we're gonna return a temporary redirect,
a three zero seven with the URL.
We also accept two more HTTP verbs as
part of this API. If we get a
put request,
then we'll actually attempt
to store the body, the redirect URL,
and the key value store. I'm not doing
a lot of validation or verification of that
value,
but we do check that it doesn't exist
in the key value store first. If there's
already a value, we'd not allow it to
be replaced.
It must be explicitly deleted first and then
recreated.
So where the value already exists or where
the key already exists in the store, we
return an HTTP conflict,
a four zero nine. Lastly,
HTTP delete and because delete doesn't really do
anything different if the key exists or doesn't,
we're just gonna return an HTTP okay.
Again, if you want to handle a this
key doesn't exist when you delete,
feel free to match instead of propagating that
error up the stack. Lastly
or very lastly, finally lastly, if we get
an issue to be verb that isn't supported
by our API, we return method not allowed.
Once we've handled that, we have access to
a issue to be status that we wish
to return to the requester.
And if we have a temporary redirect, we
will provide the location header. Otherwise, we pass
the status back with a body of none.
Nice and simple API.
Let's see it in action. So let's run
a spin build and a spin up. Now
we can open another terminal where we can
run some HTTP requests against our API.
As you can see, our application runs on
local host port 3,000.
Now I'm not going to execute arbitrary curl
commands because honestly,
it's twenty twenty three. Instead, we're gonna use
HARL and I have a test dot HARL
file. If you're not familiar with HARL, go
to hARL dot dev and you'll find a
very cool text based description
HTTP testing framework. It also has really cool
support for building assertions against the response too
and whether that be string matches, regex, status
codes, JSON,
whatever. Where we see that we're sending a
delete request or at least we're using the
delete verb to local host 3,000
on the hello world path.
The hello world path is going to be
our short URL,
which could potentially
return a longer URL with a redirect. The
delete as we've seen in the code always
returns a 200, so we just assert by
saying we expect an HTTP
200.
We then run a GET request against the
same path where we expect a four zero
four because we just deleted any redirect that
may already exist.
Next, we use a put verb
to store
a URL. Here, I'm using rockwoodishere.com.
Not a real URL,
but will suffice for today. We expect an
HTTP two zero one and if we try
the same request again, we have the same
value or a different value, it doesn't matter
because the path already exists within the key
value store.
We get a conflict and a four zero
nine. So what we expect when we run
a GET on Hello World is for us
to get an HTTP temporary redirect, a three
zero seven,
where we could build an assertion that we
have a location header that equals the value
restored with the PIP. Now we can run
Hurl
test
and point it to our test Hurl file.
And we can see that five requests were
executed and we have some debug output here
that shows we got a delete, a GET,
a put, a put and a GET.
And we can see
that all of our assertions passed.
If you want more information,
you can add a dash b for verbosity,
which will actually show you all of the
response and we can see our location header
is here. So this extension
of the URL shortener available on the fermion
blog as an example of how to do
it with their SDK
can now be enriched. It can now enable
dynamic
API driven URLs
that's stored in a key value store. So
go check it out. It's very cool, simple
interface that you can use in just one
or two lines of code. Enjoy.